[Music]
okay guys hello everybody my name is
Vitaly namer I'm an international master
and serving as the Grand Master resident
here at the same tune Chess Club today
is going to be one of my most exciting
videos I'm going to provide to the Chess
Club and to the world to our YouTube
channel and today we're going to discuss
something very very fascinating which is
engine chess computer chess as we know
the technology is surrounding all of us
today no we have it you know findell
fingers we have the phones laptops
computers cars everything is
computerized today without computers
today we cannot survive I mean we can go
go but anyway so today I would like to
discuss a very specific match which
happened just a few months months ago
between two software's alpha 0 and
stockfish now just before we start with
a with a game itself I actually like to
discuss some of the details that about
chess engines the first chess chess
engine was actually introduced in the
1960s around 1960s 1970s back then that
the the chess engines are very very weak
pretty much everybody could beat them as
well as the hardware was not that strong
as we know probably fifty years ago one
computer was in the size of a whole room
and today we have computers in size of
you know it's in our phones it's on
laptops but we but we we probably I
don't remember this but fifty years ago
the first computers that will invent it
well so so big and slow as well so this
is where we're chefs engines were when
they were born in the 1960s and 90
these since then like every piece of
technology that we have in our lives
it got poor model we got advanced it got
faster more powerful and one of the
biggest changes in engine chairs between
angels and humans happened in 1997 and
in 1997 we had the very famous match
between IBM's deep blue and Garry
Kasparov and what happened in that match
is that Garry Kasparov lost the match it
was a 6 6 game match Garry Kasparov lost
three and a half two and a half now why
was it so important that that match well
first of all it was not the first time
when a human lost an engine was not the
first time when humans beat an engine
but it was the first time when in a very
very media covered match official match
a very strong game master at a time
Garry Kasparov was treated as you know
it's almost as Magnus Carlsen today he
was on the top of the world world
champion back then and so this was
pretty much the first time when such a
important chess player lost lost an
engine so this was in 1997 by the way a
small small story about about the match
itself after the match if you if you see
today for example IBM does not produce
anymore just engines IBM decided to go
away from the chess world and there is a
good reason for that so what happened is
actually after the match was ended
[Music]
Kasparov blamed IBM that the match was
unfair and so while how was the
well besides the fact that the machine
that time could calculate faster but it
was all about the population as you know
today we have databases of chess games
that are accessible to almost everybody
you can go online and and try to prepare
for your opponent so what happened is
that before the match obviously both
teams
Kaspar of teams and ibm's teams were
trying to prepare against each other
however Kasparov's game will online so
the IBM steam could look at his games
and prepare for to those games and for
example they can make some adjustments
to the software saying ok in this
opening he might be weak in this opening
he might be strong so let's let's play
let's make the engine play against the
the more weaker side of of Kasparov
however when Garry Kasparov asked to
form IBM to provide deep blues engine
chess games they refused to do so
so you can kind of see if how it might
be unfair you know you know what I know
what you are playing you don't know what
I'm playing it's not exactly equal so
back then the you know Kasparov was we
didn't have Facebook or Twitter if as
far as I remember but even then when
somebody with a name like Gary you know
went to the media and you know announced
those accusations
obviously it created some negative
aspect to IBM and they decided to to get
to get out of the chess world so this is
just a small story about that match ok
so since then since 1997 a once the
match was won by IBM people still try to
beat engines we try to beat them lots of
players played against them in a matches
oedema kramnik Vishy Anand the pool of
sometimes successfully sometimes
not so much basically going head-to-head
against against machines and see what
happens now
the next most important thing happened
in about the year of 2005 in the end of
2005 there was a new engine came out and
the engines name was ripka we've got
translating from from Russian it means a
small fish now to be honest I have no
idea why they called it small fish I
guess it's just the imagination of the
people who created the engine itself but
that was the engine now what was special
about that engine is that it was a
little bit more creative and it got to
the rating of 3,000 points
hello so just to compare with with every
with what we have today with the other
chess players that we have today Magnus
Carlsen and the top just players in the
world about 2828 50 or 60 was kind of
the record that we had that we hit and
obviously once an engine hits that 3000
mark well no man can can ever beat that
and that's pretty much what happened for
firm 2 from the year of 2005 and no man
could beat on equal terms the engines
now we tried to to make some some
matches between between humans and
engines but the engines would have to be
in some kind of a disadvantage for
example we would start with a pawn up or
two pawns up but even a few matches were
conducted between grandmasters and chess
engines and grandmaster got two pawns up
and even then the grandmasters lost the
match and two pawns is a lot it's a it's
a big advantage not just one so so
really after 2005 we never had the
chance to beat them now going going to
this today to nowadays how how are the
let's let's look at first of all at the
chess engines today that we have if you
go to this website it's called a
computer chess dot-org that UK this
basically this this websites this
website has all the chess the chess
engines available today it is the top
ones as you can see it is being updated
pretty much almost a few days this
number forty 40 means that they play
between themselves for the moves forty
minutes to 40 moves and basically this
is how the rating of the chess engines
is is being made they play against
themselves
okay the play gets themselves in a chess
tournament
which is called at EC EC and this is its
website at EC see where that means the
top chess engine championship and every
year just like a World Championships for
human we have the World Championship for
engines just to decide which engine is
the current is the best one so as you
can see today that the chess engine the
chess engine that I was discussing ripka
is only number 17 on the on the list I
mean how how can it be I remember in
2005 I was one in my truck I would say
prime years of my chest my youth my
youth years I was very young and
energetic and I remember that when this
engine Rivka came out I used to have a
coach and that Coach immediately got
this
he bought this chess engine and I
remember him saying well vitaly from now
on you have to do everything with ripka
you have to analyze your games or if you
have to listen to her if you have to
play against sleep you're going to
become world champion by training with
Rivka all the time well as you can see
another world champion and for me it was
very difficult
always to play against against computer
so yes
engines although some people do like it
I really prefer to play again to play
against people I guess I like to see
during the game when you make a
combination anything like that I like to
see that no I guess people kind of
struggling you know sweating on the
chess board if you'd be the chess engine
II just don't have the same satisfaction
so this is why I never was I was never
able to to play against chess engine so
much but definitely some people use it
you use them for training so Rico today
is only number 17 with only thirty one
hundred fifty four rating points hello
so what happened well lots of people
it's a competition lots of people try to
get into this field and as you can see
in nowadays we have lots and lots of
chess engines today I'm going to just to
focus on the first or the top three
engines as you can see they the top
three engines are stock fish Houdini and
Komodo
they are all with 3400 rating points
which is a lot obviously that number for
shredder with 3200 but there is a
difference of about 100 points and in
those levels 31 3400 this is a big big
difference of 100 points for us it
doesn't really matter if we if we use
them but in in those stages it's it's
it's pretty big difference so if you do
use an engine at home to analyze the
game so I would suggest you choose one
of the top three now let's discuss about
those colors here those are quite quite
interesting to see as you can see the
the blue ones are the commercial engines
commercial engines pretty much say okay
well if you want to if you don't get it
you if you want to get it you need to
pay item a lots of people are working to
2k those engines so that makes sense the
second one the green ones they are the
ones who are free basically you can go
online
and you can download it that engine and
the last one is probably the best one
this is the orange ones they are the
open-source so what does it mean open
source basically open source means it is
free you can go out there and download
the engine but you can also make changes
to the chess engine so for example you
can say well maybe I'd like to play more
tactical chest maybe like to to
sacrifice a lot so you can make so you
can actually go to the code of the of
the software and you can make some
changes hopefully you know what you are
doing but that that's pretty much the
case and as you can see the number one
chess engine today stockfish is it's an
open source and he's number one why is
that well because people everybody
besides the team who is working to
improve stockfish us we also there are
lots of people out in the world come in
and try to improve the engine itself as
well so it's not surprising that
stockfish you know kind of considered
the world champion as of today ok so
this is pretty much about about chess
engines and in history and since again
since 2005 we have been a few teams
working on chess engines and stockfish
is the world champion but then we had a
new event coming in in December of 2017
just four months ago and this this was
was a huge boss on dnews this match and
I would like to discuss it more because
I think it people don't really realize
how much impact it had some people like
them and some people criticize the match
so let's see what happens so in 2017 and
as we know Google
in their laboratories working on what
they call artificial intelligence and
not only Google is working on that we
have Microsoft we have even uber lots of
lots of big companies today everybody
has their own artificial intelligence
engine or software however whatever you
guys want to call that Google's a called
their that artificial intelligence deep
mind and they wanted to see how how how
is the artificial intelligence is doing
against you know against humans or
against engines now probably what they
said the google said is that well if our
chess engine artificial intelligence
beats the top chess engine in the world
well definitely he's gonna be there any
any person because the chess engines
stock fish today is bidding any person
today so this is how alpha 0 was born
alpha 0 the the chess the artificial
intelligence google's chess engine so
besides alpha 0 we also Google also
traded another engine it's called
alphago alphago is the is another engine
which is for the go game the go game is
very very popular in China there is
actually there is an very interesting
documentary film on Netflix today you
can watch it it's basically it's about
alphago beating the world champion in
the goal game in that movie they even
say that goal might be more complicated
game than than chess well as a chess
player I would disagree
I guess I'm biased but in that match the
the world champion only succeeded to to
beat alphago one time
and I think that he lost three or four
games and he looked he lost the match
not sure I don't think that there are
any drawers over there so so enough ago
he beat him and you know we we've seen
many times and artificial intelligence
for example as of today we we see
artificial intelligence in uber or in an
other pretty much every every car
manufacturer is trying to to make
autonomous cars right so we don't need
to drive them so the color is gonna
drive itself but you know we already
have those kind of engines we have them
in airplanes we have them in elevators
in cars so it seems like robots are
pretty much better than us you know they
are faster than us they are stronger
than us
yeah it seems it seems pretty strange do
you guys think that we as humans are we
still any better than robots yeah yeah I
agree with you I think that one of the
things that we might still beat robots
is imagination that's that's one thing
and one of my students also said
emotions we have emotions but robots
don't even a I but even today I know
that some artificial intelligences
software's they are working on creating
art and composing music so well not that
far not that far into the into the
future if you guys saw the the famous
Terminator movie so obviously lots of
lots of people kind of afraid of the
future I say you know embrace the future
and worse worst case we have Arnold
right
I was gonna come and save us but for
example I just said in the news you know
we have this we have this issue
global warming everybody knows it's
coming everybody knows at some point we
might be doomed but actually they're
using artificial intelligence in order
to find a solution for that problem what
if you use what if you use deep mind to
to solve the solve global you know
economic issues or health issues what if
artificial intelligence is going to you
know kill cancer to help in the in doing
that and that's those are the benefits
as well so we don't have to only be
scared by that okay anyway so back to
the match alpha zero teams approached
you know they played a privately-held
match versus stockfish so again it's not
it was not part of the TC EC a
championship it was privately held and
they played against themselves 100 games
and the result was is that alpha 0 128
games and drew 72 games with zero losses
now it sounds pretty devastating in my
opinion though it's not as devastating
if you think about it if one of us is
going to play a 100 game match against
Magnus Carlsen and we lose 28 times but
we but we draw 72 times it's not so bad
it's not so bad now from that in that
from that match there were only 10 games
which were released to the public
only 10 games so why we'll only 10 games
were released to the public out of those
100 games anybody knows yes please so
people cannot copy the engines okay
interesting idea
well I think that the idea of releasing
only ten games is because in those and
all of those ten games alpha zero one so
when you release only the games that
that alpha zero one that's why people
thought that alpha zero destroyed
stockfish but it's not true I mean there
were so many draws as well so they're
trying just to amplify the effect that
emotion that okay he's the strongest one
and probably those winds will also the
most beautiful ones as well I wish that
we could that we could see the other
games as well I'm not sure if they will
ever be released to the public but I
would be really interesting to see what
happened there now usually the the chess
engine matches are pretty boring I have
to say you know it's lots of drawers but
this game that I selected today I call
it the ultimate machine war this is my
personal favorite I think this game is
one of the most beautiful games that
ever played and why why would I want to
show this game what can we learn from
this game well first of all I think that
no one today can become a strong chess
player without the usage of technology
things like databases and engines and
and game analysis and if we if we try to
upload this those engines and look at
what he's doing on the chess board it
would probably help us understand them
better okay while using them now number
two is you know every time I watch watch
commentaries and there is life the
transmission of games and people lots of
comments on different websites the is
usually also a chess engine involved and
he's showing his lines and I always I
will see one of those comments well this
is a this is an engine move like we have
no idea why is suggesting this move but
this is it's an engine move and I want
to show you that even even a chess
engines they have they have the
ideas every move has a reason okay
and then the plans that alpha0 played in
this game were quite quite remarkable
and we can use them in our games and the
third one the fill the reason why I want
to show you this game is because of the
opening choice that is played by by
alpha zero by the way from now on I'm
going to refer to alpha zero as AZ just
gonna be easier for me hey Z versus SF
okay
so opening a path or as we know that
even that the first move that we make in
a chess game Mike might change the
course of the game we know for example
you know some some moves are just giving
us some kind of a just maybe very minor
advantage maybe I can start with beat
three it doesn't mean that why this is
losing his advantage because the bishop
can be fatal don't be too it's still
useful but white will not get the
advantage however if white starts with
the first move g4 for example well we
know immediately that white isn't
disadvantaged black is actually it's
better for us to play black even though
we are the second one to move why is
that well because of g4 becomes a
weakness and in addition f4 and h4 also
becomes weaknesses so in the chest in
the chess world we know for sure that II
for d4 sometimes c4 and Knight of three
are the best options right this is the
those are the most common moves for us
to start the game
but even then there's probably some kind
of a difference between those moves I
mean one of those moves has to be better
right because it's him it's him it's
kind of a mathematical equation one of
them has to has to be better right so
it's interesting to see what what alpha
zero is choice was now there was a
research paper which was published
together with those games and you can
find this research paper over here and
basically it shows us each the research
paper showed a few diagrams
and here are the diagrams so they took
the you know the most popular openings
and basically they wanted to see which
one ones would be preferred by alpha
zero and as you can see here for example
if the graph is going up that means that
he likes it likes the opening and it
plays it more and more if the graph is
not showing almost at all for example
the Kings Indian defense the kid that
means that he doesn't like the opening
so it's very very interesting to see you
know the choice of opening that a fazil
chooses because after all it's almost
the world champion okay so in this match
one more thing to mention there were
basically three differences between
alpha 0 and in stockfish first of all
the speed the speed alpha zero could
calculate eighty thousand positions per
second versus seventy million positions
of stockfish that means that alpha zero
is slower hmm very interesting how kind
of a slower engine beat somebody who is
faster we're going to discuss it today
number two and one of the most big
biggest one is the learning time the
learning time as you know stockfish is
an engine which was developed by humans
it was developed all over the course of
a few years five or ten years now
however stockfish had only four hours to
learn chest basically they gave them the
moves and said okay you are on your own
right now so only four hours it's pretty
much like I would teach my four-year-old
sister how to play chess in in four
hours and she's gonna beat Magnus that's
pretty much putting it out in our
perspective and number three is the is
the database usage again similar to what
happened in the IBM's match with Garry
Kasparov stockfish had had access to the
database which is very useful as you as
you probably know and officer did not
however what
fazil did in those four hours is that it
played against himself for four hours
it created his own database that's quite
amazing it's pretty much like I'm gonna
say to you okay you are watching this
video going to stay in your room for the
rest of your life you can live forever
you won't have access to anything else
besides just the regular chessboard how
would you improve we're going to play
against yourself pretty boring but
you'll still improve okay so let's see
what happened in the game this this
ultimate machine war game that I
selected today in this game alpha zero
decides to play Knight of three as we
seen alpha 0 decides not to play less
and less efore efore the e4 move is less
common for alpha zero now what about 93
how do we decide between Knight f3 d4
and e4
well technically those those three moves
complement each other we know that we
can have a transposition of moves
between Knight f3 c4 and d-force for
example lots of the players play d4
first d5 then c4 and then I have to at
some moment so we can kind of get a
transposition of most so he decides to
start with Knight f3 Knight if 6 was
played by stockfish and now c4 so right
now we are in the ready defense
be six play by stockfish d4 and ecigs
ok so we transposed into the queen's
indian defense and one of the most solid
openings i actually played with black
myself a few times but a pretty good
opening for black and for white as well
okay so here there are lots of options
for white white can either develop the
knight on c3 i can also play title plate
3 but why decides to play g3 to French
at all his bishop and I have to say to
you that since becoming a professional
coach for the most of my life I've been
playing for myself and today I'm trying
to explore new openings and I had this
debate with myself what do I teach my my
students it was about a year ago it at
each mall a folder I teach d4 something
else and this is when I came up with a
new opening which I called the Hydra
system and surprisingly alpha 0 is
actually playing really really really
similar to the hydro system so I was
very happy to see that it's almost like
I was like winning the the million
dollars the bingo so jittery and now
Bishop a6 in this position if I flip the
Boyle Black has two main options it
needs to fetch her to the bishop to b7
or to a6 now both of those moves
considered pretty good usually I tell my
students always ask yourself what is the
damage what is the weakness of my
opponents last move not only the goal
but what's the witness the witness of
whites last move AG trip is that we know
that the bishop is probably going going
to go on to g2 when the bishop is going
to go to g2 the bishop is no longer
going to defend the c4 pawn so this is
why Bishop a6 was played immediately
attacking this the c4 point
okay so how should how should white
apply the main line here the most
popular line according to the database
is beat Lee this is the main line the
fridge is defending the pawn with a pawn
and then Bishop goes to before check and
then Bishop d2 Bishop e7 and eventually
black who is going to play something
like d5 c6 and get a pretty comfortable
position well this is where we see a
first deviation by alpha zero and a
Fazio played this move Queen to c2 Queen
c2 is very common move in the Queens
gambit and if Queen's pawn opening there
are pretty much two three ideas why
white wants to play the move Queen c2
the first one is simply to defend the
pawn on c4 the second one is that he
wants to defend the pawn the square e
four and the third one is that
eventually white wants to bring one of
his rooks to the D file just in front of
the Queen on a d8 so for example if
black tries to play very passively like
Bishop d7 then white can play something
like e four immediately and then chaos
so I can even push a five and then I can
choose between Bishop g2 and Bishop to
d3 and wife has a very big space
advantage which will give him the upper
hand in the game okay so Queen c2 was
just played in the game and this is not
a novelty though thousands of games that
were played by by white playing this
move Queen c2 I had to face this myself
as black a few times well again what is
the disadvantage of this move Queen to
c2 is that it is less defending the
default point and this is why many times
in the Queen's Indian and in the
nimzo-indian black is using this move c5
which was played by by stockfish
immediately attack in the
at the pawn on d4 well why do you
usually reply to this move on c5 we can
either ignore the threat so let's say we
can play something like Bishop to g2
just ignore it we can defend the pawn me
maybe with E to E or we can take on c5
all we can play pawn to d5 so which one
is the best so in order to answer this
question I would like to share with you
something that I share with my students
today if we go to the first position in
on the chessboard and let's say white
plays d4 first move which is one of the
popular moves and black plays c5 goes to
the Banali defense y will be the best
move here for white yes d5 exactly that
is correct not to defend the pawn not on
the pawn I for the night not to take the
pawn because then the bishops going to
take on c5 but d5 this move d5 is
intended to expand our space as we get a
space advantage also black cannot can no
longer take his knight out to c6 well
similarly as I said in the game alpha
zero is following my plan my system the
hydro system any place again
d5 now it looks like a sacrifice this
move d5 now first of all if black does
not take the pawn again we know that
after Bishop e7 for example white will
play e4 and get the get the advantage so
black takes on d5 upon takes 25 and now
of course black cannot take on D on d5
this is just a small trap why is that
well because of a simple check queenie
for the queen the queen checks the king
and if if we block with a bishop over
the queen then we lose the night and if
we block with an i
then we lose the Rakhi on it pretty
simple to see but not so obvious
I had a few games that online blitz
games that I caught a few a few players
on with his trap so 90s d5 is bad so
black decides to retreat with his Bishop
to b7 in order to attack the the pawn
again now this is technically a
variation of a white which is a gambit
which means that white sacrifices a pond
in this in this variation why do I have
to sacrifice it now because if I play a
4 here and try to defend the pond with
all of my strength then black can simply
play this move queenie 7 queenie 7 is
going to attack this pawn on e4 and not
only to attack this pawn but even if we
tie to the fan of the bishop DT for
example we are going black is going to
take this pawn on d5 using the pin that
was created on the King so if au doesn't
work now well what else do we have to do
we have to keep on developing our pieces
so Bishop to g2 was played now for
example if black has has a dilemma he
needs to figure out who I want to take
this pawn with the bishop do I want to
take this [ __ ] at this point with a
knight what do I do
well I have to take this point now the
correct move is Knight taking on d5 now
why is the bishop taking on d5 no not so
good although it looks much more logical
to immediately put the bishop in front
of our Bishop it's because why I can
play this move Knight to c3 after Knight
c3 basically black is losing a temple he
has to retreat the bishop he cannot give
up the bishop otherwise this the h1a a
diagonal would be just too too weak and
so he would have to waste another move
and so that does not make lots of sense
for black so he usually takes with a
knight so not xd5 why just castles
black just develops his pieces 96 and
roof to d1 as we said that was one of
the ideas of Queen c2 so we saw this
again the smooth defending c4 at this
controlling efore square and bring in
the rope to d1 very very common in
Queens pawn defenses openings okay
although white is attacking this knight
on d5 black has no time to defend the
night and black is playing this move
Bishop to e7 Bishop to e7 was played
still it's it's one of the main lines
again it's not a novelty yet we'll move
number 10 it's all very known play if
not not very forced but pretty much the
main line and the idea is that white
cannot cannot take on d5 and this is
simply because black would play Knight
to before forking the rook and the Queen
and he's going to take the rook next
next time just a small trap for for
white as well so in this position white
has tried many many moves such as a3 to
defend the before the be Foursquare
Knight c3 to attack the the 95 e for the
same idea and the bunch of Queen moves
will be three Queen a for Quincy for 23
24 25 and Queen Queen to a5 bunch and
bunch of Queen was obviously every move
with the Queen I will either attack the
knight on d5 or will take away the Queen
from the fork that was created a fazil
chooses Queen to a queen to f5 Queen to
a5 not only attacking the knight here on
on d5 but also looking at those pawns on
h7 f77
as well so and now black does need to
retreat his Knight neither of six was
played and now efore
it's important to mention that this
movie for although it looks like it is
blocking our Bishop which is not so good
for us but if the if the the pawn on is
still dynamic which means that he can
still move forward or be exchanged this
this would be pretty good and obviously
the idea is to play e5 for example you
black tries to castle here which looks
like a logical move then we play e5 the
knife has to move and then black is
losing the d7 g7 pawn so black is
playing g6 attacking the Queen Queen a4
is being played and now Castle and the
idea that after a five black can move is
knife to h5 with a temple on the Queen
the Queen goes to g4 still one of the
main lines in this position now we see a
first deviation by starfish the main
line for black here is to play this
Queen B eight by the way when I say the
main line it means that it's the most
popular line this is what was played the
most common in the database so Queen b8
is the main line the idea is simply if
if white takes you with a queen then the
row can come to d8 and skewer us nice
little trap and if we take here with the
rook 27 then black and play Bishop c8
also nice little skewer this is the main
line well a stock for the size to
deviate a little bit and place the rook
to e8 rook to e8 has played just the
transposition of moves 93 9 v Queen b8
and Knight to d5 always move forward the
935 is very very powerful and also it
creates a small trap if black takes on
e5 then Knight takes on e5 Queen takes
e5 check and Bishop takes on b7
how do we how do we see it by the way if
I would ask the question well why is 95
as a bad move well the way we see it is
that we have to calculate the forcing
lines first which are checks which are
captures which are threats we look at
them first and this is one of the one of
the reasons why alpha 0 is stronger
although he was slower because he's
stronger because he is more efficient
for example in this position maybe alpha
0 would say ok I'm going to look at the
checks first Queen takes g6 it doesn't
work then I'm going to look at the
captures first and so on and so on now
on the other hand stockfish would
calculate this position and he was maybe
it would just go systematically from
left to right let's say he's gonna start
with this pawn a 3 a 4 B 3 B 4
Ruby 1 Bishop d2 Bishop e3 and so
falling and so on okay so the idea was
that this alpha zero is just much more
efficient if the forcing lines don't
work then we go going to go into
something more positional so obviously
stockfish does not fall into this easy
trap he plays Bishop to f8 again the
idea of Bishop to f8 we know that there
is a reason for behind every move I to
to them by Bishop I want to bring my
Bishop to venture to him and most
importantly now I bring in the rope to
attack there the pawn on e5 Bishop f4
was played by by alpha zero I just wanna
I just want to develop my my Bishop 90 x
f4 is impossible because what's the
weakness of this move Knight f4 is that
he get it gives out gives up this
squirrel and f6 so we can check him with
a fork pretty easy to see four four
engines but for us the thinking process
would would help here so queen c8 I was
played to get out the Queen out of out
of this diagonal otherwise a six might
have been coming and now white made us
look at the most strange move he played
this move h3 hmm this move h3 why do we
need this movie hd I mean usually when
we play h3 it's when we are not fair and
shadowed and we are just trying to get a
lift for the King or window or into
escape after after analyzing this game
for for many many times I understood
that blacks the blacks idea was actually
to somehow move the pawn at some point
and exchange the Queen's because if we
exchanged let's say if I take out the
Queens here of the board right now black
will be with a pawn up and the
weaknesses that we have with with where
the King here will not be so substantial
there won't be felt as much so this was
the idea to defend the Queen in case
black is going to try to exchange Queens
97 as you can see in in this position if
I flip the board just for a second you
will see that black really does not have
a lot of space and it's very important
in chess to to have to have space
because otherwise you your pieces won't
find the best squares and pretty much
stock fishes is feeling probably like a
tuna can fish tuna
okay so 97 he's trying to exchange some
some pieces 93 look at this very very
amazing prophylactic move black once to
exchange the night he wants to jump to a
5 and white says no way I'm gonna play
93 I'm going to prevent the exchange of
nights and I'm going to prevent the
night from coming to a 5 and this is
really what I what I think was one of
the beauties of alpha zero artificial
intelligence is that he does play play
very creatively he does understand
positional chess what does it mean a
prophylaxis and we will see it more
coming in Bishop c6 was played to defend
this pawn on this 7 because after we
moved the rope is attacking the
different pawn and now wrote to d6 and I
nice block it with the rook as human for
us it will be very difficult to make
such a move because we usually don't
like to put the rock in front of the
bishop however it's also about the
concrete at the concrete calculation we
know that the knight cannot move
anywhere because it's going to get taken
on the 5 and d5 so the rook feels pretty
good here Knight g7 was played again the
idea is to bring this Knight to f5 so
how do we prevent this we play rook to
f6
look look well this beautiful ruckus
usually we don't see it in a very nice
look lift one two and three Queen b7 was
played by stockfish Bishop h6 so now why
decides okay this Bishop on fo is finish
his job his job was to defend the pawn
here on the five the job was to attack
the Queen here on b8 so let's try to
annoy the King Bishop h6 95 and finally
black succeeds in exchanging a few
pieces now he didn't exchange a few
pieces it does feel better however now
what after exchanging the dark square
bishop that those witnesses really
really gonna come into play in the
future and this is exactly what alpha0
says okay he says okay you have those
weaknesses let's let's let's go and it's
going to visit you over there
let's see what's what's gonna happen so
queen edge for the immediate threat by
the way is again an action move an
action move queen equal age for attack
and here on h7 I want to bring my Knight
to g5 for example if they just place a
695 I want to check my tea on h7 Knight
takes and now Bishop takes on d5 simply
winning a piece
so this is why starfish played Bishop c6
so far I think that I have explained
every move that was played by starfish
and every mother was dead before zero so
no surprises
Queen h6 queen is coming in rook a e8
and wrote to d6 and now look at this
nice blocking position this is what we
call a positional sacrifice sacrifice a
pawn to get the our pieces much much
more active route d6 also has a threat
we played here the threat is if I play
just a random move that a six is to take
this night and if the pawn takes let's
say here all rook takes or anybody else
again we have this move Knight to g5
there is no defense from the mate on h7
rocky 7 does not work because of rook
takes on f8 checkmate so stockfish sees
that threat and he decides ok I'm going
to take the knight here on the three
he's just too dangerous
Bishop takes f3 and Queen to a6 the
Queen comes out of the threat and also
attacking the a to pawn and now alpha
zero decides to create another very
creative plan which we have seen we see
this more and more often even in the in
this candidate tournament we saw it this
round today
played by karaoke if I'm not mistaken
when he played this move
h4 suddenly we attack on the h5 very
very peculiar idea I mean usually we are
taught in chess that we have to do
everything in the center center and
suddenly we go h4 very strange well
here's the idea if the Queen takes on a
two they will play h5 and basically we
expose the h-file take and if check if
it takes on g6
then now we have this elevator down rook
to d1 attacking the Queen and preparing
group each one and a checkmate on h8
there's basically no difference against
that so stockfish sees death and he
plays Queen a5 he's trying to put his
Queen here on a1 checking and taking the
e5 pawn if we lose the e5 pawn the if
iPhone is almost like a glue in the
position and we cannot do that so after
he comes back with the rook to d1 C for
rogue d5 again defending the pawn on e5
and attacking the Queen Queen e1 check
King G to C 3 we have C we see a few
exchanges h5 everything goes by the plan
still wife is upon down but his pieces
look a bit nicer his King a safer rookie
7 and now why decides that his Bishop on
f3 is not so good if I would ask many
people which which piece is it looks bad
for y to be definitely not the bishop
looks good I did defense the the rook
defends the pawn but really it has
nobody to attack usually when we French
it to the bishop
we want to attack the rook here on the
8th the bishop here on b7 may be an item
opponent e6
so alpha 0 AZ decides to transpose the
bishop to a different diagonal not a
square but a diagonal and this would be
this diagonal just looking here at the
King and he decides to play a Bishop to
d1 Queen e1 and Bishop to b3 right now
it doesn't it doesn't seem like much
like okay the bishop is just jumped two
squares but in the future it will be
very very useful
rook da toes played rock to f3 now he
decides to transpose this rooks Queen d2
is played Queen g4 Bishop d1 and there
are some minor threats like root X of F
7 so the Queen can take on h5 Queenie 4
and another interesting idea was played
by alpha 0 instead of taking on g6
which many of us would do very very
early in the game he decides to play h6
if we take on g6 pawn takes on g6 then
there is no advantage here we just lost
a few temples one two three temples just
just on taking this pawn on g6 so alpha
zero decides to play h6 and the idea is
that first of all it weakens the back
rank so we have some back rank mate
ideas and white will also want to bring
his Queen on g7 at some point 97
attacking the rook rook the 696 and our
Bishop to BT the bishop comes back to b3
with a pawn sacrifice another pawn
sacrifice so we have so alpha zero is
two points down and the whole idea was
for alpha zero to play rook to d5 what
does it mean I mean the Queen is just
getting attacked but it's she's in the
center right I mean she can go whatever
she wants to e4 c7a 1 and h8 for example
now the idea behind this maneuver was
the sacrifice was that if the Queen goes
that say to e4 now white can play Queen
B - and eyeball this checkmate on g7
still had a checker because of the kick
of the night but once we move the rook
somewhere and we take the knight
there are lots and lots of checkmate
ideas okay so in this position again
after why it sacrifice the pawn if I
have with the Queen has the stock fish
realizes I have to keep the Queen on
this diagonal but there are only two
squares h8 and a1 that's it
no I can't move anyone else well if I
place the Queen on a1 the idea is this
idea was to play rook to c3 completely
cutting of the Queen and again the plan
is Queenie 325 and queen g7 at some
point
so stockfish decides to play Queen to h8
now I'll tell you guys if you find
yourself playing Queen h8 the Queen each
one in one of the games it's not a good
sign
so Queen before was played attacking the
rook 95 and another amazing sacrifice
made by AZ rook takes e5 pawn takes e5
but the whole idea was not to take back
on c5 the whole idea is for us to bury
this Queen on h8 just to bury how do we
do it let's just forget about this
attack right now how do we bury the
Queen we need to put our rock on f6 so
that is the question how do we put the
root of 6
well we play Queen to h4 also skewering
the two rooks Rudy to e8 was played he
has to defend and rook to f6 rook a
faith and quintal force so look at this
position just together just for a second
let's just stop here it's very
interesting if you give it the beginner
chess perish let's say you just thought
somebody had to play chess what would
they do
they would count the pieces and you
would say okay I have a rope and two
passed pawns for a bishop I'm better I
would choose black but if you really
give it to an experience just player
he's gonna say wait a second what about
this Queen on h8 she's supposed to be
worth nine points but she's more useless
she's all useless then the rook here
okay so this is again the beauty of this
game is the positional understanding
that this artificial intelligence had
and basically right now black had
nothing to do he has to keep his rooks
here to the defending the pawns on f7
the King has nowhere to go the Queen has
nowhere to go this pawn cannot go
so he has to stop moving the pawns a
5-wood that does not help him
g4 d5 exactly it tries to sacrifice a
pawn here on d5 Bishop takes we keep the
bishop on this diagonal a foe and g5 a
tree and in this position what actually
wins the game for alpha zero is the one
thing that we haven't mentioned yet and
this is this pawn on a2 so every pawn
matters
and now why just plays Queen f3 and grab
this pawn on Italy and creates a passer
and the very interesting thing happens
here stockfish unjustifiably understands
that this queen is completely useless on
h8 and decides out of desperation to
sacrifice the clean under 6 politics on
G on on g6 rock FC 8 and this is pretty
much lost why it just one supposes a
screen to a battle square and starts to
push the pawn and here is where the game
ends because there's just no way to to
stop this pawn for example if rook a7
and I play a five if the rook takes only
five I can probably just take on the 7
check and there's gonna be some kind of
a some kind of a checkmate okay so this
is in my opinion was probably one of the
best games in history especially between
chess engines if the viewers at home
have any questions please comment on the
video you can send an email to to the
Chess Club
or email to my personal email my website
is powerful chess calm and the final
words for those of you who are afraid of
the machines taking over the board I
have a message to the robots we'll be
back
thank you
[Music]